this one is absolutely wild easy cheese
goodbye tooth enamel kimchi i really
liked it why it's not a fan it's not
gonna sit well
that is good oh i'm gonna have another
piece hi i'm hannah i'm the world's
okays mom and i am so pregnant and i've
been asked so many times to
taste my cravings that i had with our
youngest henry and see if i still like
them so i figured what better way than
to try them right now while i'm pregnant
and see if i like them again not only am
i going to do that i'm also going to try
cravings submitted by my instagram
followers and try my current cravings
and see
what stayed the same and what's
different wish me luck if you haven't
realized by now i am pregnant again i
know i have said about a million times
that each of my kids was gonna be my
last but the universe just
decided i wasn't done okay none of my
previous pregnancies have been
particularly rough i've not had much
morning sickness i've had nausea and
like persistent nausea but not so
extreme that i'm like
throwing up
oh my god my eyes are watering this time
around i am so sick i'm sick 24 7. i
i can't talk about it this time around
i'm so dang sick i am so dang sick all
day every day to the point where some
days i'm non-functional i cannot get out
of bed i have to be seated in bed at a
specific angle to like keep
this is gonna be a fun video all right
we are kicking off trying the old
cravings with one pretty weird one from
when i was pregnant with henry
there's a blue one and i'm really
excited actually to see henry try it to
see if he likes it
what i cut out my mouth you want to try
this in your mouth
okay
so i'm going to have
olives
i know i'm getting it ready olives with
easy cheese
so when i was pregnant with henry i
really craved a lot of salt i remember
distinctly loving pickles
olives cheese and so the thought of
spray cheese on olives just sounded so
good to me you remember this oh yeah i
remember
[Music]
it's not good this time around it was a
big old no i think i liked it last time
and i think i ate it several times when
i was pregnant with henry but this time
around it was an absolute no oh that
makes me sad because i really enjoyed
food so much with henry
this time around i'm like throwing up
every day what i really wanted to know
was whether or not henry would like it
he seems to be wolfing this down
but i'm gonna have to cut them off
because that's a whole lot of sodium
okay now let's get a glass of water
honey okay
no by far the most popular craving that
i was sent when i asked was
flaming hot cheetos
dipped in sour cream i feel like flamin
hot cheetos are just one of those foods
that you usually eat on their own so the
idea of dipping it into stuff is a
little unique all right get this nice
and coated
i really liked this it is a perfect
combo especially if you love spicy food
but your stomach is not in the best
shape because the sour cream
really calms the spiciness of the flamin
hot cheetos
i dip it for you okay here
[Music]
do you like it
yeah
i'm only one that has a tiny
what do you think wyatt
they loved it my boys are flaming hot
cheeto fiends like i have a nightstand
bag and a pantry bag of flamin hot
cheetos that are mine and mine alone i
do not share so the fact that i shared
my flamin hot cheetos and let them dip
them in sour cream was heaven for them
they really loved it all right i got a
very interesting
craving submitted from a follower they
said they just liked lemon slices with
sugar
which to be honest sounds really good
right now in theory to me it sounded
like edible lemonade it sounded really
good goodbye tooth enamel i'll miss you
[Music]
huh
oh my
whoa i don't know if i just got an
unbelievably sour lemon
oh that hurt
oh my god i was not expecting to have
that reaction i guess i didn't realize
just how much sugar and water goes into
lemonade because the second i popped it
in my mouth it was like
painful
[Music]
you can't even bite it
wyatt's tactic was to kind of get
sugar with a side of lemon juice and so
he really enjoyed it that's good
i think if i had tried it that way from
the start i would have liked it a whole
lot more so next up i actually had a
craving of my own donuts dipped in queso
got my donut and we're gonna dip and see
if
this really was what i wanted
oh my god
do not write this off as gross like give
it a chance i'm telling you
this was spectacular
it was one of the best things i have
ever eaten hands down the salty cheesy
sweet combo with like the fried donut is
absolutely perfect
what do you think
i would almost compare it to like a
slice of cheddar cheese on apple pie
what do you think hon
good
that is good oh i'm gonna have another
piece but it's just
so good is this going into my
hypothetical cookbook of weird foods
that i feed my kids yes two steps two
ingredients
heck yeah you got a beautiful snack
hello oh my god scary when you don't
look at yourself all day and then this
is the first thing you see
kimchi
so this follower suggested
ramen with a kimchi
pickle
salad seasoned with lime and salt so
i've got my pickles
got my kimchi and i'm gonna finish up my
ramen now so not pregnant
this meal is my jam like i would inhale
this i love everything listed on there
it's delicious kimchi is one of the best
foods ever and i just regularly eat it
plain out of the jar but
weak stomach pregnant hannah wasn't so
sure how she was gonna react to this i'm
gonna try to get everything in one bite
so i have kimchi and pickle and ramen
i would really like this on a normal day
like i would love
all these together
are og hannah's favorite foods
but right now hannah
it's not going to sit well
i couldn't eat it
and that's one of the really frustrating
parts about being really sick when
you're pregnant
is you want to eat it like it's a food
you know you like and i wanted to eat it
but i physically couldn't
[Music]
you like it
what's your favorite part
the kimchi
enjoy
do you like it
do you want to finish this
yeah okay you can have it so matt and
jackson absolutely loved it no surprise
there wyatt the wild card was a little
bit of a different story
it's not going to be too spear the spice
came
[Music]
no
i did not like to tease this is not
zucchini it's a pickle just lick it and
you'll see it's a pickle
see try
get the nudes
i guess why it's not a fan you will
never guess
what i am
chopping this for this is a
follower-submitted
pregnancy craving vanilla ice cream with
peppercini and pineapples on top i think
if it was ice cream with pepperoncinis
or ice cream with pineapple
that wouldn't be weird but pineapple and
peppercini and vanilla ice cream just
sounds like a lot of
flavor layers that don't necessarily
mesh i'm be honest the smell alone of
the pepperoncinis is sending me into dry
heaves
please
do you see one at all yeah i see your
arm
oh yummy
you wanna try some henry
try
some sure
here we are vanilla ice cream
it's not terrible
it's actually a lot milder than i
thought it was going to taste
because of the vanilla ice cream
but it kind of has a weird aftertaste
something in those pepperoncinis like i
said i don't really like pickles this
time around
it just
it didn't
it didn't work for me what do you think
why
[Music]
not your fave
jackson do you like it
henry's just picking out the vanilla ice
cream
what am i tasting
pineapple
so i didn't tell matt what was on it
when i gave it to him and he really
liked it and then when he found out that
there were pepperoncinis on top suddenly
the story changed peppertinis are banana
peppers right yeah oh my god
you liked it
[Music]
well anything with ice cream is good
all right today i'm trying a follower
submitted pregnancy craving
i don't know how this one's gonna go to
be honest um
but it is
a lot of things i haven't tried so of
course we saved the wildest for last
these are honey buns
and it's kind of like a sweet almost
cinnamon roll but without the cinnamon
it looks like um
this as the bread
a chicken patty american cheese and a
fried egg as a sandwich and it actually
weirdly sounds kind of good to me right
now so individually these are all things
that are delicious and what pregnancy
brain does is it says yeah these are all
good but what if we ate them all at once
so while i was cooking this
beautiful monstrosity um my stomach kind
of took a turn
not feeling great
oh
not my best um so we'll see how this
goes i don't know if i should wait it
out
ah
but look at that look at that oh
my god
are you serious
i think i maybe shouldn't have done two
honey buns so i'm gonna do it like an
open face sandwich
this is a weird thing for me
because i have chickens for the eggs i
don't really eat eggs
plain like cooked eggs i don't really
like them they give me a stomachache
this is one of those foods that is so so
delicious but i knew immediately i had
to be very careful because like one bite
too many would ruin it for me forever
that's another thing a lot of people
don't talk about with pregnancy is if
you overdo certain foods you can
literally ruin them for yourself for the
rest of your life
like i still can't eat pot pies from
when i was pregnant with henry okay
let's try
the boys loved this
oh my gosh this was like heaven for them
it was like a dessert you know it's like
crunchy chicken sandwich with sweets and
american cheese it was like a dessert
for them they were so in love with this
and same with matt
that shouldn't be illegal is it good do
you like it it's pretty good but i can
tell it's like
not healthy no that's really good though
i mean look at that
that looks gorgeous i'll probably make
it again for my boys but maybe i will
stick to like a regular sandwich so in
conclusion i think this time around was
super different from last time around
because i'm very sick if anything this
time around my kids found more foods
that they liked versus me so
maybe we found some new foods for my
kids to eat and i'll just have to try
them when i'm no longer pregnant you
know there aren't many ways that kids
can participate in a pregnancy and so
food is a really fun way to include them
and help them feel connected to their
new sibling and make them feel like
they're a part of it so if you're
pregnant and you already have other kids
i would highly suggest trying this you
can even do it with just one food
because it is such a silly and fun way
to get the kids involved and excited
about having a new sibling or if you're
not pregnant and you just want to try
some wild food combos absolutely go for
it 10 out of 10 recommend
so that's all for now i'm hannah and
what did you think of those cravings
would you try any of them and do you
have any cravings of your own right now
message me on instagram and maybe i will
try them but if you'll please excuse me
i am
not feeling good so i'm gonna lay down
for a little bit until next time
[Music]
you